what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here John Humphrey here wearing Jeff
bearskins Peterson's shirt that he you
know got from patreon we got mail outs
and I thought I'd wear it in first sweat
in it a tad bit yeah for sending it out
Queens the stony shore new album doubt
today go by villains it's great we're
gonna check out from a screen rant on
awesome YouTube channel and a great
website you know there's a girl on
screen around I'm Casey Spears fiber
I think videos so many times I keep
forgetting how to say her last night but
like her to come on the chat line never
a tell Tejano anyway get over here ten
actors who are forced to replace other
popular actors I was and here's a list
compiled under who we're not going to
know about these stories can you guess
which would be these emojis are
referencing make it beauty in this video
to find out Pelham one two three
Fresh Prince of bel-air I remember
that's the Fresh Prince of bel-air mom
she's very outspoken about her well
definitely was a different person as she
was replaced
Daphne breed replaced the original
Vivian banks played by Janet Hubert
starting the third season of the show
social media wasn't flourishing at the
time no one really knew the reason
behind the change in actors back bends
Janet's absence and replacement seemed
to be due to creative differences as it
turns out it was far more complicated
than that
oh yeah funny and a good actress she did
not get along very well with him he went
a little nuts it is said that she wanted
the show to revolve around her she was
not keen on the been twenty-year-old
Will Smith coming in I'm The Fresh
Prince news
a decade after all who's making close to
a quarter of a million dollars at the
time and then all of a sudden nothing
sometimes it's a little hard to take the
back seat when someone up-and-coming
comes in and steals the spotlight
Mark Ruffalo
the Incredible Hulk if you remember
though Edward Norton had the privilege
of playing the Hulk as well but things
didn't work out in the long run no one
knows for sure why Norton doesn't play
The Hulk anymore but there may be some
reasons why waters from a lot of
creative control when he took on the
role part of that control was him
completely rewriting the script the head
ton studio apparently didn't like his
darker story and decided to work with
Zack Penn's original script the media
caught wind of this and it was turned
into a much bigger deal than it needed
to be it created even more of a rift
between someone else it was probably a
blessing in disguise that Norton stepped
down because he was able to work on some
great movies such as moonrise kingdom
Birdman and the grand budapest hotel all
of which are very diverse and suited him
very well absolutely Ryan Gosling bones
really Ryan Gosling too much too young
for the role actually it wasn't that at
all Gosling had put on 60 pounds for the
park and the producer directors were not
see much of ego change he said he put on
the weight because that's how he thought
the character of Jack salmon who was a
grieving father should look a 210-pound
man with a gut who's most likely
depressed Jackson and Gosling did not
see eye to eye on how the character
should be played as it was due mostly to
the fact that there was limited
communication between the two in the
pre-production process Gosling dropped
out only two days before production
began Wow member Mark Wahlberg
eventually starred in the role the movie
was adapted by a book of the same name
written by Alice sable which was
released in 2002 it was an instant
bestseller and was popular with the
teens younger adults do you like Mark
Wahlberg's performance in this movie or
would you rather see Gosling or two
rather sing Gosling's chubby Gosling
looks like chubby John a little bit I
look like chubby rosy replace someone I
did not know that career-minded woman
who ends up having a one-night stand and
getting pregnant Katherine Heigl was
soon the new leading lady after Hathaway
dropped out
that's what I would have been maybe
that's the reason she dropped out having
not experienced motherhood herself she
felt she was not right for the part
I can feel Muslim yeah imagination
inside I say to women portraying Whitman
is humorless and uptight while all the
men are convenient fun-loving it's
strange why she would wait until the end
of filming to state her opinion on the
role however we don't know exactly what
was going on behind the scenes
even though Heigl may have disapproved
with the movie she gained popularity and
played the character very well after her
role in knocked-up Heigl went on to star
in movies like 27 dresses and the ugly
truth CY the romance Holly there Robert
Downey jr. requested Colonel James
Rhodey Rhodes was replaced if you
remember Don Cheadle took over the role
for Terrence Howard after the first
movie the movie blew up at the box
office making over 318 million dollars
in the US and the studio decided to go a
different direction with the character
Brody
Howard was supposedly offered only a
small fraction of what he was supposed
to make such a [ __ ] and the studio
said that the sequel was gonna be a
success
with or without him then in comes Don
Cheadle Tony's best friend liaison
between Stark Industries and the
military and Moore machine when he dons
his own set of armor to help iron man
out her chair our chemistry between
Cheadle and Robert Downey jr. was a
little different between him and Howard
but they still have similarities the
dialogue is still humorous and the
repartee between the two of them never
gets old
Cheadle was allotted a lot of screen
time in a sequel and we were treated
with great scenes between the two great
actors do any of you miss the original
Rhodes I do I do it's got a different
vibe that's all I think you're a place
on the map really go yeah movie
definitely requires an explanation as
far as the casting is concerned whether
or not they technically ended up
replacing himself in the movie American
Psycho he played Patrick Bateman a
wealthy New York investment making
executive who hides his sadistic side
from his friends after bail was
originally cast Leonardo DiCaprio was
somehow hired at the 1998 can Film
Festival by Lionsgate executives this
was right after Titanic apocalypse and
propelled DiCaprio to land more roles
Bale was surprised by the news as was
mary harron the director
he refused to meet with DiCaprio saying
he wasn't right for the part in Tokiko
that would have been a good Joker yeah
Leonardo's take on it is a little
different he had said he wasn't
satisfied with the film's direction and
had problems with the script and plot
plus he wanted to work on a different
film so we ended up abandoning American
Psycho it is kind of ironic that marry
him yeah Wall Street guy he did pretty
well playing one is Jordan Belfort in
the wolf of Wall Street maybe he just
needed some time to grow out of his
boyish phase Strebel yeah I agree
oh I think I know this one Hugo Weaving
would be Provenza died for you Brenda
please remember the fifth of November
the gunpowder treason and plot
if you've ever seen V for Vendetta you
remember this excerpt from the
anarchists by the name of V most people
know Hugo Weaving who gained popularity
by playing agent Smith in the Matrix
trilogy was cast as V so some babe
probably didn't know this but James
Purefoy was originally cast as the
master hat say you may have remembered
Purefoy from a Knight's Tale playing the
role of Prince Colville who saves Heath
Ledger from being executed Purefoy quit
production about six weeks into the
filming of V for Vendetta stating he did
not feel comfortable wearing the
infamous mask for the entire movie he
was upset that no one would ever see his
face and it was a great challenge acting
wise actors concerned that need to take
place whilst wearing the mask as far as
anyone's concerned weaving did not have
any issues and was eventually cast in
pure boys place even though weakened
space was never shown the iconic voice
of his made up for it it probably held
to the chomsky brothers who wrote and
directed the matrix also wrote V for
Vendetta
we have put in a good word for Hugo he's
got a good voice
what
[Music]
we held Houseman gave of throats if
you're a game of Thrones fan you lose
like oh yeah yeah playing the role of
Daario naharis you know The Bodyguard
advisor in part-time love we're gonna
find out why Branca Trentino forgotten
all about long haired and screen
originally playing the role he laughed
after the very popular HBO show's third
season to play in the trans that's why
you left to do that the television
series screen has said the most
important thing it is like his family
Game of Thrones may have been taking him
away from them for too long or the
possibility of making more money for
starring in a major movie franchise was
too enticing for him whatever the case
the kennel Houseman was thrust into the
role the show has gone on he captured
our attention with his bravery and
smarts as did Daenerys I prefer that
released out of screen time and it's a
protective dimension to the show along
with the love each her side with
Daenerys and screentime hi candy
Dario's dialog and dedication of the
Khaleesi make for good television
his screen time should increase even
more as the show progressed was he
coming back alien James Cameron made it
big when he released aliens in 1986 he
had a little different feel from the
original but still wowed audiences with
the special effects in style everything
didn't go completely right though as
James remarked who was initially going
to play the role of corporate Wayne
Hicks left the project I could see that
with Cameron yeah I can see the
Terminator in the abyss which Cameron
also directed Cameron apparently liked
working with the guy and he helped get
his name out there he received a phone
call on Friday after rebar left asking
if he could play the part and then began
shooting on Monday he did a great job
considering he was thrust as the role
right away without the extra rehearsal
period he did not partake in the
roundtable reading of the script for any
army drills since they were playing
soldiers on the screen they usually take
the actors out with a drill sergeant who
puts them through the routine apparently
being hated to do that so he was happy
to jump oh yeah hey I heard Spike Jones
is her starring Joaquin Phoenix's she
surprised audiences it's a heartfelt
story about a lonely
divorced greeting card writer named
Theodore who ends up falling in love
with an operating system
Theodore seems like a fairly normal guy
who enjoys playing video games and
occasionally hanging out with his
friends when he isn't working
however I hope things start to change
when he purchases the operating system
it's the first operating system that is
artifice
we intelligent and his program to meet
his every need Queen Latifah at States
it's not just an operating system it's a
consciousness Samantha Morton was
originally cast as the voice only role
of Samantha she found my system which
Phoenix falls in love with she completed
all of the film for the movie and then
out of nowhere was recast with Scarlett
Johansson Spike Jones decided that was
not right to the role my technology
seems to be advancing even more rapidly
at AI operating systems don't seem as
far-fetched as they may have in the past
how do you feel about having AI in our
society other movies have touched on the
subject in different ways and her brings
about the romantic side of it in an
interesting question of our list take
smart guys subscribe to Screen Rant man
there's a great job of their website - I
just like to rant it's greed I already
forgot the actresses names but The Fresh
Prince of bel-air won yeah yeah I mean I
watched all the Fresh Prince of bel-air
and as a kid I didn't notice it
I didn't either I mean I watched it on
TV and like scattered episodes so I have
a great grip on the entire ensemble yes
so that one flipped completely over my
no but just recently I think it was this
year or last year the original actress
has been very vocal I was wrong Suicide
Squad Suicide Squad or a concussion one
of those too bad now think Will Smith
and talking [ __ ] on him and everything
and she like did it twice who wouldn't
like a couple month period I think this
was concussion because this was when the
whole like we're not gonna go to the
Oscars thing oh yeah yeah yeah and then
she stepped up she was like I played his
mom on TV alright yeah I'm gonna lay
down the law for a sec I don't know why
she won't think the show could possibly
be centered around her the show was
written for Will Smith the fresh yeah
we've talked plenty before about Mark
Ruffalo and Edward Norton yeah I found I
think Mark Ruffalo is probably a better
suited actor for that role so yeah
especially because of his demeanor and
he you know cuz Bruce Beck I feel like
he is such an okay here's how I put it
everybody Norton is already kind of
intense yeah
these are any kind of intensity whereas
mark ruffalo is a really like relaxed
kind of dude so to have the comparison
between Hulk and Bruce Banner works
better I think yeah well yeah I feel
like and then Norton Hulk would Hulk out
a lot more often the Mark Ruffalo I
believe the whole like I know I want to
I want to I'm kind of unassuming when
I'm just Bruce I am obsessed with Ryan
Gosling I did see these photos before
where Ryan Gosling put on more weight I
didn't see all that was the lovely bones
I didn't see all the lovely bones that I
watched like a good chunk of it on
television like the first 40 minutes or
whatever Mark Wahlberg can be pretty hit
or miss for me you can either be like
exceptionally awesome or just alright so
the fighter or the happening why had
like 50s child or just great dramatic
actor and I honestly would have
preferred his take on the father
character it seems more like a character
choice and Ryan Gosling gaining weight
for a grieving father who probably
drinks and is lazy that made more sense
to me then in shape Mark Wahlberg know
this guy maintains his life but you know
one of the some overwrought so won't
they help me beginning through this
grieving process
yeah it doesn't seem like it's as much
as the forefront of Marbury I think they
have really different acting styles so
Ryan Gosling would have brought a ton to
that movie I didn't know about Anne
Hathaway being the first person chosen
for knocked-up I did not either know
Katherine Heigl it's such a fascinating
career she's I think she's amazing and
knocked up and then she like egged on
the film and then she has like this [ __ ]
career now I think Anne Hathaway would
have killed it too I think both of them
are a great choice and but I also think
Anne Hathaway would have killed it well
you know and she made up for it with
love and other drugs yeah I feel like
that was her kind of in that realm that
like romantic drama comedy thing all
right Terrence Howard I've said it
before I do prefer him there's something
about his chemistry that feels more
natural for Robert Downey jr. I feel
like because Robert Downey jr. was cast
that are probably trying to find a
specific actor that would be tailored
for Robert Downey jr. as well Terrence R
is known to be a little egocentric and
it kind of shows in almost all of his
roles
and yeah I don't know kind of having the
two buddy egos but also loving trust you
know Yoshio brings just a very different
dynamic I feel like I like Don Cheadle's
Rhodey because I like Don Cheadle and
he's a good actor and maybe it was just
the first impression that Terrence
Howard left on me but there is something
special about that dynamic that doesn't
feel quite as natural to me moving from
yeah and I kind of agree with you and I
don't know if that character robber feel
100 percent natural again because it's
hard to recast somebody just right off
the bat yeah you know Terrence Howard
was memorable part to me yeah man yeah
and I've never found Don Cheadle to be
memorable you know it's like I've always
liked him and I've never I've never
hated what he's done I've never sat
there going oh wish Terrence Howard was
back but doesn't lose roadie and yeah
really even Iron Man 2 which had a lot
of Rhodey well yeah it does and that's
some personal conflict for Tony but you
could recast a lot of those fights with
just him and yeah shave that's the party
scene out of the movie
American Psycho with DiCaprio being in
it I think DiCaprio and Christian Bale
there's a lot of differences but there's
also a lot of similarities in terms of
commitment yeah like their emotional
commitment and their intensity I've
thrown myself into this yeah and they
have this certain intense energy I
remember years ago I came with a story
idea I think I told it to you where I'm
like I think it'd be so cool to have the
Capri on Christian Bale star in this
movie and I've always wanted to see
these two actors come together in a film
DiCaprio doesn't change his voice and
mannerisms as distinctly as Bale can do
that yeah but there is enough
similarities between their intensity
they'll both grow crazy ass beers yeah
that is where the unites the unit Holmes
and and you know hey man one day
Christopher Nolan's gonna put them in
his co-stars together they can't happen
and after seeing the big career DiCaprio
has developed I could see him doing an
American Psycho role now now definitely
not Titanic era DiCaprio come now
DiCaprio I could see that Daario naharis
I remember watching Game of Thrones
wondering what happened to that actor
and then I think two episodes of the
replacement guy was like I think that's
the same character yeah yeah well my
only issue with that at the time was
like oh you cast another guy with dark
hair and a beard
I recognized the other guy because of
his long hair and square jaw the other
guy though they're gonna want to
transporter refueled I don't know much
about his acne to be honest but I
thought he was cast for his looks more
in a row yeah and I feel this other guy
has a much more intriguing demeanor and
personality while his looks look very
similar to a lot of other people in Game
of Thrones I think his personality fits
in better and I could see him being cast
more for the performance than the looks
yeah totally and I and I got that sense
to the guy who originally played him is
more pretty and I kind of I think he's
smiled a lot more this is when they
replaced him I thought not only was the
look different but the character felt
different like his choices the
mannerisms and all that so that's what
threw me the transport Iran and and then
Deadpool I can Hannah bow oh yeah he's
uh what's his name
he's guy killed Rick James remar being
Hicks and aliens I could definitely see
that the base on how that guy's tends to
seems like a remark yeah it seems like a
remark type of character what I found
fascinating is how Michael Biehn just
transition to that role because he's
like one of James Cameron's go-to guys
he might have worked with James Cameron
as much as Arnold has worked with James
Cameron oh man is he's in the abyss okay
normal has true lies but in the t2
special edition michael beans in that
one oh so I think they both equally
worked with Arnall he is honest yeah
yeah but hearing how because he's so
badass in that and everyone is very
military trained and he's beloved and
his beloved easily loved memorable
characters he didn't do any military
training and he really didn't want I
thought that was funny you got away with
that and he's totally believable in the
movie as Hicks I think he's way more
believable as Hicks and he is as uh Kyle
Reese yeah and the one with her I forget
the actresses name that was the original
one that makes me curious as the filming
process of it when I watch the movie I
was wondering what sculpture hands it on
set we she actually interacted with
Joaquin Phoenix off camera she on the
phone with him what were they doing her
because it sounded like such a natural
back and forth yeah I remember hearing
that at least the way they shot a lot of
it was they had like a booth and they
would talk I guess it was the original
actress would talk with him and they
would have the scenes that way I think
don't quote me on that but I believe
that's when I read from Spike Jones and
then yeah they just looped in Scarlett
later interesting I wonder how the
original actress feels about this
because like that I think Scarlett
Johansson did a great job and I love
that movie if she was just not the right
choice for the role I get it but you
know kinda sucks to be like oh this neat
part well guys thanks for watching the
video today hope you enjoyed our
commentary portion and the reaction if
you liked our reaction hit the like
button if you don't like it hit the like
button 100 million subscribers subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification Bell John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram and check out our
patreon become a picture on a jet today
patron eject that's the word it's it's
not a very good word exclusive stuff